Ferguson Missouri is marking the fifth
anniversary of the death of Michael
Brown jr. this morning the unarmed black
teenager was shot by a white police
officer who says Brown attacked him a
grand jury decided not to indict the
officer Brown's death led to months of
protests and drew attention to police
practices nationwide Jeff McGee's has
been reporting on policing in America
five years after Ferguson all week he's
in Ferguson Jeff what can we expect
today
well good morning behind me this is
where Michael Brown was shot and killed
five years ago and you can see here in
the middle of the street there is a
growing memorial because they will honor
his life this weekend with a memorial
service but there will also be calls for
justice and continued changes in
policing as you know earlier this week
we told you about our ongoing
investigation which looked at police
practices since Michael Brown's death
our investigation revealed changes that
police departments across America say
that they're making to confront possible
racial bias we reached out to more than
150 departments in big cities nationwide
and found that 57% of those who say they
have implicit bias training added it
after Ferguson but most said that they
don't have a way to measure its success
we recently sat down with Michael Browns
father Michael Brown's senior policing
has changed in your view in those five
years so so so so yeah so you don't
think there's been enough change no it
could be more so clearly he doesn't
think that there has been enough change
in policing across the country and here
in Ferguson he will have a press
conference and we expect that he will
call for his son's case to be reopened
Anthony Jeff thanks